[موسيقى]
حياكم الله قالت عده منظمات انسانيه
عالميه ان خطر الجوع في المناطق المتاثره
بالحرب في سوريا يتنامى بشكل سريع وحذرت
التقارير من ارتفاع معدل اصابه اطفال بسوء
التغذيه خاصه مع تفاقم ازمه الغذاء بسبب
ارتفاع اسعاره نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش
في
محورين حجم الخطر الذي يتعرض له السوريون
جراء تفشي الجوع وسوء التغذيه في
البلاد اسباب تعثر وصول المساعدات الدوليه
الموعوده الى مستحقيها في
[موسيقى]
سوريا يقول برنامج الغذاء العالمي ان اكثر
من 4 ملايين سوري بحاجه الى مساعدات
غذائيه وانه لا يمكنه الوفاء بالتزاماته
كامله في هذا الشان وتقول الامم المتحده
انها تبذل جهودا حثيثه لادخال عمال
الاغاثه الدوليين الى مناطق القتال في
سوريا في ظل هذا الوضع يبرز السؤال عن مدى
كفايه حجم المساعدات الدوليه المقدمه
للشعب السوري ومدى سهوله وصولها اليهم
في حرب سوريا من مات او على وشك الموت
جوعان عيون العالم المشدوده الى جنيف
ومسلسل نزع السلاح الكيميائي ترى وتسمع عن
ازمه انسانيه مرشحه للتفاقم ازمه هي
الاسوا في العالم منذ 20 عاما اي منذ ازمه
الاباده في رواندا الصور التي تقشعر لها
الابدان في الغطه الغربيه بريف دمشق تعكس
جزءا من ماساه وطن وفق الائتلاف الوطنيه
السوريه المعارض يعاني ما لا يقل عن 25
الف مدني في الغطه من حصار مطبق لا غذاء
ولا ماء ولا كهرباء منذ شهور دقت الامم
المتحده نقوس الخطر اكثر من مره ما يقارب
7 ملايين شخص بحاجه الى مساعده غذائيه
المساعدات الدوليه تبقى قليله مقارنه
بالحاجه المتزايده وايصال تلك المساعدات
مستحيل في بعض الاحيان بسبب القتال لا احد
استجاب للمطلب الملح لاقامه ممرات انسانيه
حتى من غادروا البلد الى مخيمات اللجوء في
الاردن ولبنان والعراق وضعهم ليس افضل لما
ما في كان اكل اخواتي كانوا بيجوع كثير
بيجوا لعندي او لعند الماما بقولوا له يا
ماما
جوعانين تتوقع المنظمه الدوليه وصول عدد
اللاجئين الى 3 ملايين نهايه العام الحالي
هم الان وفق المفوضيه العليا لشؤون
اللاجئين اكثر من مليوني لاجئ عدد
النازحين داخل سوريا يتجاوز 4 ملايين مع
الاشاره الى ان ارقام المنظمات الدوليه قد
تكون اقل من العدد الحقيقي للاجئين
والنازحين منذ بدايه الثوره في مارس
2011 وصفت المفوضيه العليا لشؤون اللاجئين
الوضع بانه نزيف يضاف الى هذه الماسا عدم
قدره الدول المستضيفه على تحمل عبء
الفارين من جحيم حرب تتاجر بها اطراف
كثيره من لم يقتل بالسلاح في سوريا قد
يفارق الحياه بسبب الجوع او بالاحرى سياسه
التجويع المفارقه ان نزع السلاح الكيميائي
قد يكلف اكثر من مليار دولار مع تاخر
ملايين الدولارات المطلوبه لانقاذ
المواطنين من سوء التغذيه المتاخر الاكبر
هو سلام وطن ما اقصى واكثر
اوجاعه موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
نيويورك مهند هادي مسؤول الملف السوري في
برنامج الغذاء العالمي من اسطنبول فايز
ساره عضو الائتلاف الوطني السوري ومن غوطه
دمشق الناشط الاغاثي خالد طور وابدا معك
سيد مهند هادي على مدى اكثر من سنه ونصف
ونحن نسمع عن ازمه انسانيه الامور في
تفاقم الى اين
وصلت طبعا الامور في سوريا في تفاقم على
كافه الاصعده على السبيل الانساني الازمه
الانسانيه في سوريا تتزايد ومعاناه الناس
تتزايد يوما بعد يوم الازمه السوريه ازمه
هي ازمه سياسيه بامتياز لكن الموضوع
الانساني والحل الانساني هو الحل الموجود
حاليا الذي يقدمه برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
وباقي منظمات الامم المتحده حتى حتى يوجد
حل سياسي لهذه الازمه نعم ولكن ربما يعني
السؤال التي الذي يخطر على بال كثيرين رغم
هذا
التحذير سمعنا حتى منظمات تقول ان الامر
وصل الى درجه غير مسبوقه وغير مقبوله خلال
العقدين السابقين وحتى اكثر رغم ذلك فهي
في
ازدياد طبعا تزداد يوما بعد يوم طالما
الازمه السوريه تتفاقم المعاناه الانسانيه
تتفاقم في في كافه المحافظات في سوريا
الموضوع لا يخص منطقه واحده في سوريا
الازمه السوريه اثرت على على جميع
القطاعات في في سوريا الاسعار يعني اصبحت
مرتفعه جدا حتى حتى الذين غير النازحين
يعني غير مشردين داخل سوريا لا يستطيعون
في جزء كبير منهم لا يستطيع تامين
احتياجاته اليوميه من المواد الغذائيه او
او غير ذلك الازمه السياسيه لابد لابد ان
تحل حتى حتى معاناه الناس تنتهي مع هذه
الازمه خالد طف يعني ما تقوله المنظمات
شيء وما تعيشونه انتم على الارض ربما شيء
اخر ما درجه
التباين رب العالمين افضل الصلاه وتم
التسليم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين نحن في غوطه دمشق او في الريف
الدمشقي
يعيش حوالي
800 نسمه في طه الشرقيه فقط هذا الرقم من
الناس يعيشون محاصرين حصارا مطبقا من
حوالي عام
كامل مع انعدام كامل لكل مقومات
الحياه النظام اطبق الحصار على الغوطه
الشرقيه من اين تاتي هذه الاغاثه من
المنظمات الدوليه او الحقوقيه او
الانسانيه اذا كان الطحين يمنع من الغوطه
الشرقيه المواد الغذائيه تمنع من دخول
الغوطه الشرقيه وغيرها من المناطق من
الريف الدمشقي لا ياتي لا تاتي المساعدات
لا من المنظمات الاثيه ولا من غيرها ربما
تذهب
الى اللاجئين خارج حدود سوريا اما داخل
المناطق المحرره الناس يموتون جوعا وقد
ظهرت بوادر سوء
التغذيه الموت بسبب الجوع عند الاطفال
وعند الجرحى الذين يمنع عنهم الدواء
طيب ما هي مسؤوليه ربما يعني اتوجه بسؤالي
الان الى فايز ساره من اسطنبول ما مسؤوليه
الحكومه المؤقته في كل
هذا مساء الخير لك والساده ضيوفك وساده
المشاهدين يعني يعني بالبدايه اود ان اضع
ملاحظات سريعه على التقرير الذي اعته
جزيره في هذا
البرنامج يعني عند عندما يقول التقرير ان
هناك ازمه اعتقد ان هذا تعبير ملطف
الحقيقه ان هناك كارثه وهذه الكارثه هي
كارثه مضاعفه اذا نظرنا اليها بصدد
المناطق المحاصره هناك كارثه في بالشامل
السوري وحتى في مناطق اللجوء السوري هناك
كارثه انسانيه تتعلق بالغذاء وبغيره لكن
الغذاء هو احد تجسيدات هذه الكارثه النقطه
الثانيه وهي العدد الذي الذي ورد في
تقريركم عم عم يقول التقرير انه هناك
25,000 والحقيقه انه العدد اكبر من من هيك
بكثير بالنسبه
للغوطة
اذا سمحت لي اريد ان استوقف في هذه النقطه
يعني عندما تقول لمنظمه انسانيه هناك مئات
الالاف وهناك عدد كبير وهذه الارقام غير
كافيه هذا ربما يعني لا يكفي لان السؤال
والمنظمات هذه تحتاج الى توثيق الى
معلومات دقيقه الى اي حد نجحتم في توثيق
وتوفير الاحصاءات التي يمكن ان تساعد
المنظمات في الدفع باتجاه تقديم المساعدات
يا سيدتي ببساطه ليست المساله مساله توثيق
وارقام الى اخره الحقيقه ان ان وهذه
النقطه هي الثالثه في تقريركم ان ان ما
يجري في المناطق المحاصره هذا يتم بفعل
سياسات النظام الذي يمنع دخول الاشخاص
وخروجهم يمنع دخول البضائع والسلع بما في
ذلك المواد الغذائيه ويمنع ايضا حتى
المواد الطبيه هذه المناطق تكاد تكون
معزوله كليا عن العالم هذه المناطق لا
تعاني فقط من نقص الغذاء وانما تعاني من
نقص الخدمات هذه المناطق لا كهرباء فيها
واذا قلنا انه لا كهرباء يعني لا لا لا
اجهزه انترنت ولا وليس هناك موبايلات
بمعنى انه وسائل الاتصال مع العالم
الخارجي تكاد تكون منعدمه الا ما خلى و
وتم هناك وتم هناك تصرف من نوع خاص هذه
هذه الاوضاع عموما هي الاوضاع الاشد
كارثيه في العالم منذ نهايه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ليس الامر له علاقه بالع
سنه سنه الماضيه هناك كارثه انسانيه
حقيقيه في الداخل السوري هناك اكثر من 5
ملايين سوري مشردين خارج بيوتهم واماكن
سكنهم الطبيعيه و في دول الجوار هناك نحو
4 ملايين لاجئ سوري بالمحصول ليسوا هؤلاء
الذين يعانون فقط من نق ص الغذاء والدواء
والحاجه الى اغاثه حتى في المناطق التي
يسيطر عليها النظام هناك الكثير من الناس
الذين بالفعل هم بحاجه الى اغاثه لانهم
فقدوا اعمالهم فقدوا معيل ايهم فقدوا
مصادر عيشهم وفقدوا كثير من ممتلكاتهم وهم
يواجهون كبقيه
السوريين ارتفاع الاسعار نتيجه انهيار سعر
صرف الليره وافتقاد السلع والبضائع التي
لم ت تصل تصل من المستوردات وهي لا تنتج
في الداخل السوري لان اليه الانتاج
الصناعي والزراعي في سوريا تكاد تكون قد
صارت معطله ليست هناك معامل بما في ذلك
معامل الصناعات الغذائيه تشتغل في عموم
سوريا وليست والاراضي نفسها ليس فقط ان ان
الفلاحين لا يستطيعون زراعاتها بسبب
الاجتياح والقصف واعمال التدمير وانما لان
الس سطات قامت باقتلاع اشجار وحرق محاصيل
وهذا ليس سرا وهذا ليس اكتشافا هذا هذا
عموما تدلل عليه كل التقارير الصحفيه
والتلفزيونيه التي صدرت خلال العامين
والنصف الماضيين من عمر الثوره اذا هناك
تدمير شامل نعم تدمير شامل مهند هذ ربما
القضيه تسميتها بالكارثي هذه سمعناها منذ
فتره يعني قضيه التوصيف هنا ليست يعني
المشكله المشكله ربما التي يطرحها كثيرون
لماذا لا تصل المنظمات الانسانيه لماذا لا
يصل الصليب الاحمر مثلا الى الداخل او
الهلال الاحمر الى
الداخل سوريا بينما تنجح مثلا لجان تحقيق
تنجح الامم المتحده في ارسال
بعثات للتحقيق ولكن لا تنجح في ايصال
المعونات
سيدتي يعني صحيح سميت كارثه او غير ذلك
هذا ليس مهم المهم انه توجد معاناه
انسانيه وتوجد معاناه انسانيه انا كما
ذكرت في في كافه المحافظات السوريه برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي يقدم مساعدات غذائيه
للسوريين في ال 14 محافظه اضف الى ذلك في
دول الجوار كافه لكن اريد ان انوه انه في
ال 14 محافظه نحن لا نصل الى كل الاماكن
في اماكن لم نستطيع الوصول اليها منذ منذ
اشهر وطالبنا طرفي النزاع ان يسمحوا لنا
بالدخول وبتقديم المساعدات واكون صريح هون
المعوقات من الطرفين المناطق التي فيها
نزاع التي فيها اشتباكات لا لا يسمح لنا
الدخول اليها نخاطب الحكومه ونخاطب جميع
ال جميع اطراف النزاع امامنا اما امامنا
عضو في الائتلاف الوطني السوري يعني
امامنا عضو في الائتلاف الوطني السوري
يشكو ايضا من ان المعونات لا تصل يشكو من
حجم الكارثه تقول ان في النهايه هم طرف
كيف لا يتعاون معكم هذا الطرف اشرح لنا او
وجه سؤال لفايز
ساره
ستي تفضل تفضل سيد
مهند الموضوع انه الاماكن اللي يكون فيها
اشتبا الاماكن التي يكون فيها
اشتباك في في بعض في بعض الاوقات يعني
الطرفين لا لا يتعاونون معنا يجب وقف
النزاع يجب وقف العمليات العسكريه في
مناطق حتى نتمكن من تقديم المساعدات
الغذائيه للمواطنين المتواجدين فيها في
مناطق كثيره يتعذر علينا اعطيك مثال يعني
من من من دمشق الى الى الى حلب تقريبا
يوجد اكثر من 50 نقطه سيطره جزء منهم
للحكومه جزء منهم للمعارضه وفي بعض في بعض
يعني دائما نتعرض لمضايقات من من الطرفين
لابد من تسهيل مهمه برنامج الا
العي برنامج الادي العربي من الوصول لكاف
نقطه يعني نقطه مهمه ما الدور الذي يمكن
ان تلعبو لكي على الاقل من طرفكم تضمنوا
ان لا تكون هناك
معوقات نعم نعم انا انا انا اريد ان اشكر
استاذ مهند وادعوه بالفعل ان يتكلم عن
الامور بصراحه وشفافيه وهذا امر ضروري
عندما نناقش قضيه انسانيه بحجم الكارثه
السوريه الصليب الاحمر الدولي لم يستطع
حتى الان
ان يعني يعني يبرم اي اتفاق خارج مساعدات
تقدم مباشره للسلطه وتحت سيطرتها السلطه
هي التي تاخذ المساعدات
وتوزعها بمعرفتها وتقوم عموما ونحن لا
نمانع في ذلك بتوزيعها على على سوريين
اخرين ليسوا ليسوا الذين يعانون من الحاجه
الشديده هم ياخذون هذه المساعدات او ما
بقي منها عندما يسرقون وينهبون ما تيسر
منها ثم يبقون الباقي ليوزع بطريقه عادله
بطريقه غير عادله على مناطق مختلفه
والصليب الاحمر الدولي والمنظمات الدوليه
عموما فشلت حتى الان في ان تاخذ على
عاتقها مسؤوليه القيام بتوزيع هذه
المساعدات مباشره ودون انحياز نحن نطالب
هذه المنظمات بالفعل ان تقوم بتوزيع هذه
المساعدات مباشره وبالتعاون مع مع الهلال
الاحمر السوري الذي وان كان خاضعا للنظام
فاننا ندرك ونؤمن ان هناك كثير منه كثير
من افراده ابناء الشعب وهم معين بالباقين
ربما النقطه هنا لماذا اذا تصل الاسلحه
الى داخل سوريا في حين لا يصل الغذاء هذه
من ضمن النقاط التي س نناقشها بعد الفاصل
ارجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه الحلقه
التي نناقش فيها تداعيات تدهور الوضع
الانساني وتفاقم خطر الجوع داخل سوريا
خالد طف ربما يعني سمعت ما دار من جدل
بشان دخول المساعدات الى ال
برايكم انتم ما هو المعوق الاساسي الذي
يمنع دخول المساعدات في حين نسمع عن
دخول
السلاح
ببساطه نعم
نعم بدايه انا استغرب من كلام الاخ من
المسؤول الاغاثي عن وصول المساعدات او
المسير من دمشق الى حلب وكانه يريد ان
ياخذ الاغاثه من دمشق الى حلب نحن لا
نتكلم عن المسافه بين حلب ودمشق والكثير
من الحواجز نحن نتكلم عن حاجز وضعه النظام
بين دمشق وريف
دمشق الحاجز بين الذي يفصل دمشق والغطرسة
شريحه واسعه من الناس هذه هي المشكله حاجز
واحد يضعه النظام يمنع دخول المساعدات
الاغاثي
الى الى الغوطه
والى الحجر الاسود وما حولها من جنوب دمشق
والى المعظم الشام يمنع عنها الطحين يمنع
عنها حليب الاطفال يمنع عنها الدواء يمنع
عنها الوقود هناك يعني ازمه وقود عندنا
كبيره جدا طيب اريد ان اسالك يعني هذا
السؤال
ي خال يعني يبدو ورغم ذلك الاشتباكات
مستمره وتبادل القصف والنيران
والقناصه كيف يدخل السلاح اذا في وقت لا
يدخل فيه
الغذاء كله عن طريق التهريب طيب لماذا اذا
لا يتم
تهريب المشكله اذا نعم يعني هذا هو السؤال
هناك
نعم
نعم نعم التهريب يعني هناك هناك واضح ان
هناك طرف ايضا يستفيد
ويستثمر هذا
الجانب نسمع عن اسعار خبز يعني مبالغ فيها
بشكل كبير من منطقه الى اخرى اذا كانت
تفضل
نعم
اذا كان السلاح يهرب او اذا كانت الطلقه
تهرب هل نستطيع ان نهرب اكياس الطحين هل
نستطيع ان ان نهرب صهاريج الوقود حتى
نستطيع ان ان نخرج الماء من باطن الارض
للشرب او للاستحمام او غير ذلك هل نستطيع
ان نهرب اكياس الدواء وا اجهزه المعالجه
هل نستطيع ان نهرب هي هذه مقومات الحياه
التي يعيش من خلالها الاف الناس
ربما هذا سؤال لفايز
ساره الوضع في الداخل وصل الى مرحله الناس
تموت جوع يعني هذا ربما قبل يومين فقط
شاهدنا منظر طفله وهي يعني في وضع مؤلم
جدا جدا ماتت من شده الجوع ما ما هو الدور
الذي تفعلونه ماه ما الذي تستطيعون ان
تقدموه لهؤلاء خصوصا واننا يعني نسمع
بمساعدات ضخمه من اطراف عديده تقدم ل
المعارضه للائتلاف للحكومه
الانتقاليه نعم اولا احب ان اقول ان ان
السلاح يمر الى الغوطه والى المناطق الم
المحاصره و وبقيه المناطق بواسطه النظام
النظام يصر بالفعل على تسعير عمليات
القتال والقتل وهذا جزء من برنامجه بينما
ليس هناك في برنامجه اي خطوه باتجاه
الاغاثه نحن نطالب بالفعل وها هو صديقنا
الاستاذ مهند امامك نحن نطالبهم
برفع برفع الموانع عن مرور المواد
الغذائيه ونحن نتكفل بالفعل تتكفل
المعارضه ويتكفل الشعب السوري
باغا اخوانه من المحاصرين لا نريد من احد
ان يقدم للسوريين شيء فقط ان يؤمنوا ممرات
امنه تعبر حواجز النظم ظام في المناطق
المحاصره وهذا سوف يكفي لمرور كل المواد
الغذائيه والمواد الاغاثه الطبيه ايضا الى
المناطق الداخليه لكن الان الان ينبغي ان
يرفع وانا اوافق ان الاساس في عمليه
الاغاثه هي وقف القتل ووقف العمليات
العسكريه وهذا نداء ينبغي ان تتقدم به
المنظمات الدوليه اليوم او او امس حتى من
اجل
اغاثه هؤلاء السوريين المحاصرين وغير
المحاصرين وقف القتل عمليا يعني افساح
المجال
لتبادل السكان وعودتهم الى مناطقهم ايضا
يعني افساح المجال امام مرور بريء وحر
للبضائع والسلع والمواد الاغاثه المختلفه
الطبيه والغذائيه اما في موضوع ان
الائتلاف وغيره يتلقى مساعدات كبيره هذا
هذا نوع من المبالغه ذلك ان مجمل
المساعدات التي يتلقاها الائتلاف
وغيره لا تكاد تكفي ابدا لاي عمليه اغاثه
بالنسبه للسوريين عندما نتحدث عن ملايين
السوريين داخل سوريا وملايين السوريين
بحاجه الى غزاء هذا يعني انهم بحاجه الى
مبالغ كبيره جدا لان الغذاء هو واحد من
الاحتياجات لا ننسى ان هناك صحه لا ننسى
ان هناك التعليم لا ننسى ان هناك السكن لا
ننسى ان هناك مكملات اخرى قد اصبح ضروريه
وهي ضروريه من مياه الشرب الى الالبسه
وانت تعرفين ان في مخيم الزعتري هناك حاجه
لتامين مياه الشرب للاسف لم يبقى لي الا
دقيقه واحده فقط مهند هذ هذه المناش
والمطالبات برايك هل
ترى فرصه حقيقيه من اجل تحقيقها من وجهه
نظرك انت في
نيويورك س نعم سيدتي اسمحيلي انا انوه في
شهر حزيران فقط برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
ارسل تسع قوافل الى المعظم لكن فشلوا تسع
قوافل في الدخول الى المعظمي و ونطالب
دائما بالسماح لبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي
ولكافه منظمات الامم المتحده بالدخول الى
المناطق دائما نناشد جميع الاطراف تسع
قوافل في شهر حزيران لم لم نستطيع الدخول
فنحن نعرف معاناه الناس ايضا اريد ان انوه
هنا انه برنامج الاغذيه العالمي لا يسلم
المواد الغذائيه او اي مواد اغاثه لاي طرف
من الاطراف نحن مسؤولين امام المجتمع
الدولي عن تسليم توصيل المساعدات الغذائيه
الى المحتاجين اينما كانوا نحن في برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي نصل الى كافه المناطق في
سوريا كل شهر نصل الى اكثر من 400 موقع في
سوريا ونرسل اكثر من 1200 شاحنه فنحن على
درايه كامله اين المواد تذهب و والى من
الى الى من من توزع وكذلك دائما نناشد
جميع الاطراف واكرر هنا جميع الاطراف بوقف
الاقتتال والسماح لبرنامج الاغذيه
العالميه نحن في سوريا منذ عام منذ
الستينات نحن علاقتنا في الشعب السوري
علاقه شراكه قديمه ونعرف معاناه الشعب
السوري وسوف نستمر في تقديم المساعدات الى
الشعب السوري حتى حتى نهايه هذه الازمه
شكرا لك مهند هادي مسؤول الملف السوري في
برنامج الغذاء العالمي كنت معنا من
نيويورك شكرا لفايز ساره عضو الائتلاف
الوطني السوري من اسطنبول ومن غطه دمشق
الناشط الاغاثي خالد
طور وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر فيمان
[موسيقى]
لا